hey everyone
welcome
the most important symbol ever made
classically known as the taijitsu
and modernly known as the yin yang
this is the ultimate integral truth
compressed describing
the ineffable as closely as
possible in one symbol
representing both the monism
the non-duality as well as the dualism
the dualistic concession the descriptor
the concepts trying to describe the
non-dual the ineffable
this is true simultaneity
monism and dualism in one symbol
a really good way to understand
this most important symbol ever made is
to take
ourselves back to a thousand years ago
with zhao dunyi with across the
perennial wisdoms
across the planet
there was the formulation of these
styles of symbols
one circle for the whole
for the non-dual for the monism and
inside of it the explanation of the
dualism
in that flux the forces at play
and why was it made this way to think
about that
if you had to try and compress
the nature of reality into one symbol
that could simultaneously represent
monism non-duality
as well as dualism and try and put
the ineffable into a symbol
simultaneously with these
profound truths the most
ultimate integral truth trying to
represent that with the symbol
it's it makes sense that you would
have that circle representing the hole
or the non-dual or the monist
the circle and then inside of it the
most succinct way you
might start with well what if we put one
line through the middle and we represent
one side is good and one side is bad or
light and dark or what have you
light and day all these types of
dualisms
male female etc
but the line down the middle doesn't
explain how the two forces interplay
how they're interdependent how it's like
leela
the divine cosmic play and so that's why
as you see here in the taijitsu
on that left side you can see how the
drawing of
it is a
the two interplay they interweave
they're drawn in a perfect
way where you can see that there's
from the 2d it looks like they are
interplaying
in a 3d
and this older version of it on the left
also has a
the eyes there of the
each fish that are swimming around one
another
that those eyes
are also in the interplay and
interweaving process
whereas it in the modern conception it's
almost as though it's lost
the salience of
in the sense of chasing after the tales
of one another with the
i in each is a lot different than what
was in the og
days where you had what appeared to be
them both meeting at the center point
then meeting at the center point and
having those eyes they're pointed at the
center point
it's just that that center point is the
flux it is the ascension process
and this is sort of a modern
interpretation as well
where we've included this in
our projects where you take that yin and
yang and you add some of the cutting
edge scientific concepts into it you add
the james clark maxwell's
electromagnetic
flux when you add the electromagnetism
and you add the solenoid the helical
ascension when you add the not theoretic
dynamics as well
you sort of begin synthesizing science
and spirituality in a way that makes
sense
and we unpacked this a lot in the
exegesis of the universal one by walter
russell
where he also went into great depth at
explaining
the electromagnetic the general
radiative
right and they all in his understanding
as well
were just like that og symbol where they
meet in that middle point and that's
where the
ascension process happens across all of
it
the modern one the modern interpretation
seems to have
in a sense lost part of the dynamic that
the old one
had where it looked as though it was
more of a three-dimensional style
ascension and not so much just
chasing the tail and that last part at
the bottom
is the symphonic aspect to it where it
is
just one monism non-duality
yet at the same time the dualistic
concession
is that these are different gems around
our necks that the source light is
shining
through and so as our iris is a unique
expression a unique coloration
the pupil is what is shared as that
eye of god of source of the infinite of
the tao
of brahman and so in this case it's
important to remember that
the instruments or the gems
in the symphony are saxophones and
trumpets and clarinets and violins and
violas and cellos and
xylophones and they're different
harmonics that are being played
different melodies are being played
and people will have solos at different
times
as well and
there's an attractor in this entire
process that's why
you have like the conductor of that
symphony here in the visual
is an attractor
because the complex system of what this
is is evolving
towards something and
that is very much like the cyclicity
it's very much like the oroboros
it's very much like a recursive
functionality
the dream the illusion the appearance
this what this
is calls on itself
more of this
and it can be thought of like leela that
divine cosmic play there's
more play
that source god the infinite the
absolute
the formless
there is a process of the form
the physical the dream the illusion the
appearance
to be explored
in more and more depth
in more and more play and more and more
dancing
more and more art more and more irises
and so when you begin adding some of
these scientific concepts into the
spiritual like the knot theory the
solenoid the electromagnetic flux
when you add the analogy of things like
the symphony and the strange attractor
and things like that
to the spiritual tajittu what happens is
that
you're able to understand the unity
of the symbol the symbol itself is the
unification
of the spirit and the science into one
and so
this is by far from my
understanding the most
way for us to understand
the ineffable in a single symbol the
ineffable in a single symbol
and to sort of go back a thousand years
across these cultures around the planet
and to think
about what it was like back then trying
to
put the ineffable in one symbol because
that's what it was like it's like okay
it's one got it so there's the circle
and then it's also
dual with the flux and so instead of
putting the line
drawn right in the middle we're going to
angle the line like this we're going to
have the two
heads of each of the fish like in the
old school version they meet in that
middle point
and it looks like in three dimensions
that they ascend together
and the eyes of each of the of the fish
point towards the middle as well whereas
that style of thinking
appears to be lost in the new modern
interpretation of the yin yang symbol
as though the old symbol almost has
more depth to the concept it has more
depth
to the understanding and so this is a
very important
idea for us moving forward is to
illustrate these most important symbols
ever made
into even greater
visuals into even greater videos
and film and that's what was made with
movies like star wars is that you have
the dualistic
flux that is in ascension the light in
the dark
and yet there's not
enough yet
people that are illustrating through art
the simultaneity of monism and dualism
there's no lack it's a non-dual enigma
that's perfect and whole already and
and expressing itself as disappearance
yet at the same time
in the dualistic concession of the
mountain where
you want more and more prosperity
where we want more and more well-being
and less suffering
suffering's acting as the drill sergeant
right that's where you have the cute
little
eye which is like the white eye in the
black
fish right the black fish is like
suffering but the white eye in the black
fish
is that suffering is what births shadow
births fire right
where the
suffering acts as a drill sergeant for
awakening and so in this mountain
analogy
we actually which is the dualistic
concession where there is something to
seek there is something to become
enlightened about to reach some sort of
absolute to pierce
this veilless veil or this gateless gate
we need to illustrate this symbol
in more depth across our art across our
film across our visuals and videos
creating more and more true simultaneity
between
monism and dualism which is ultimately
why
the yin yang symbol why this taijitsu
is so beautiful why it's so important
why it's known as the most important
symbol that's ever been made
that is true simultaneity in one symbol
true simultaneity in one symbol is right
here
it's right under our noses and it's been
here for over a thousand years
across the different planetary cultures
their mystic traditions have produced
symbols that are so
similar to each other that look just
like this with the monism
that has a dualism that is acting as
some sort of an
ascension style flux a dynamic interplay
between
polar opposites which is exactly what's
seen
in the james clark maxwell
electromagnetism or the
helical solenoid or in how in not theory
everything is
interconnected and intertwined and
interdependent on one another as well
and take ourselves back in time to
a thousand years ago thinking about how
we could try and
illustrate in just one symbol the
ineffable
and that's what this is that's why it's
the ultimate integral truth
putting the ineffable into
a single symbol as close as we can get
that's what this is that's what the
taijitsu
and the yin yang that's what this is
explaining the true simultaneity
between the monism and the dualism
in a flux ascension and you can add that
oroboros aspect to it as well
where the snake eats its tail
and the sicklicity continues eternally
which is what has been happening and is
what will continue happening
that's what this is that's what we are
and we've talked about it like
consciousness or awareness that is
eternally being colored by experience
although in the appearance or the dream
or the illusion we recognize that
at the same time there is no agent there
is
no attributes we recognize that non-dual
wisdom
yet we also recognize the dual wisdom
of there being a mountain and
recognizing that consciousness
is being colored by experience
is a pretty high point up the mountain
versus being an egoic contracted
separate entity
that has yet to dissolve as a sugar cube
into the hot tea of infinity
so we recognize and we're able to hold
this true simultaneity
and that's this ultimate lesson this
ultimate integral truth
the monism and the dualism in one symbol
the ineffable in one symbol as close as
we can get
and seeing how the old-school version of
it actually has that profound
additional component to it where the two
poles are actually
meeting harmonically in that middle
point that
is an ascension and the two eyes are
also pointing upward as well in that
three-dimensional ascension that seems
in the 2d version to somewhat be lost
and to also add the scientific
components as well
in order to try and better explain
a synthesis between the two as we
go deeper in the ineffable to
synthesize what the modern day science
and materialists which is ultimately as
quantum mechanics is proving just
energy it's all no thing yet
that physicalism interplays with the
spirituality so perfectly as well as the
the symphonic component of the
of the oneness as well as the unique
diamond necklace that is around each of
our necks that's refracting the source
light in a unique way
like our iris is colored that that's our
unique instrument that is being played
towards this
strange attractor
which is that godhead in the oroboros
and so all of these symbols across these
cultures over time
are trying to get us to recognize the
true simultaneity of monism and dualism
in one symbol put the ineffable into
our psyche just just stamping it
boom there it is and now it's up to us
in modernity
use film to use visuals to use art
to take this to the next level
and this is a big part of what we're
doing right now with our visuals and
projects is taking this
type of ultimate integral truth to the
next level
so it's not this or that
but it's this and that
so it's not that the left politically is
right and the right is wrong or the
right is right and the left is wrong
it's that there's a sorting algorithm
that happens where the best codes from
each
are uplifted and they're merged together
into one and that same thing is true
about indigeneity and modernity
or about hollywood and silicon valley or
about
quote physicalism and consciousness you
know there's all of these different
science spirituality there's all these
different usa china there's all these
different ways to portray the two
that the dirty bath water gets drained
the old codes get archived
while the beautiful babies come out and
get merged into one
so that's the sorting algorithm of the
codes
and that's very true again in that
simultaneity
it's all about simultaneity
simultaneously
the monism and the dualism the
non-duality and this
flux ascension that is happening the
mountain being so
important at the same time as being an
illusion
that the mountain is that suffering
as a drill sergeant that is creating the
seeking
impulse to enlighten and to become
union yoga mysticism hypnosis become one
with the absolute become one with god
become one with your source
one with infinity to recognize that
unique
gem that diamond necklace that is
already around your neck refracting that
source light
to stop seeking externally for happiness
found in objects or the worldly
pleasures but to turn
inward and recognize that my
consciousness is what i am seeking
my awareness is it this is the awareness
of god that is shared across all of us
it's the awareness of our source
awareness of
the infinitude the eternity the dao
the brahmana
and to have respect for things like this
because in modernity it seems to be
quite lost
the idea that in one symbol we can put
an ultimate integral truth that
simultaneously holds the monism
and the dualism
that's all i hope this was valuable and
if so like the video subscribe if you
haven't also
leave a comment below would love to hear
from you about this
definitely take the idea of the most
important symbol ever made
and recognize the true simultaneity of
it and then
add art add visual components add film
components to this
to disseminate it even more fruitfully
across the world
and to catalyze that awakening to
the true nature of who we are and why
we're here
and leela the divine play the cosmic
play
i love you very much thank you for
tuning in
and share the video also with people
that will find it valuable
we'll see you soon infinite love
peace